ici à Bourges la comédienne est
maintenant scène Sarah alias à Pixie
Vixen a dédié sa passion au service de
la femme à travers les feuillages elle
les invite à assumer leur féminité cette
pratique glamour inspirée des pin-up des
années 50 va réveiller en moi ma part de
féminité
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour tout le monde bonjour
bonjour mesdames
d'initiation
la femme fatale donc la femme fatale
elle est très sûre d'elle elle ne doute
pas elle a une part de masculinité parce
que c'est la patronne c'est vous qui
avez le pouvoir
vous savez vous allez et vous ressentez
ça profondément
[Musique]
ah oui c'est très décolleté la robe
j'assume ma part de féminité je sens que
ça monte tu vois Pixie comment as-tu
rencontré justement cette discipline les
feuillages alors je les ai rencontré en
2017 quand j'ai vu chez rilili Darling
sur scène il y a eu un élément
déclencheur où tu t'es dit allez j'y
vais je passe la porte je franchis le
cap parce qu'il faut oser quand même
pour se lancer dans les feuillages quand
mon fils aîné il y a eu plein
d'injonctions qu'on donne aux maires
d'être bien comme il faut de répondre à
beaucoup de choses et ça m'a oppressé et
là les feuillage burlesque était là et
ben il a explosé avec eux je pense mon
engagement féminisme qui était aussi
très présent et comme ça va ensemble ben
c'est parti de là en fait qu'est-ce
qu'elles ont envie de transmettre au
plus au public j'aimerais bien que tu
leur demandes justement on va se poser
la question attention les filles
j'arrive
[Applaudissements]
bonjour Daisy
bon alors Daisy qu'est-ce que tu veux
transmettre sur scène comme émotion j'ai
envie de transmettre du plaisir au
public quoi qui se disent ouais en fait
on peut faire ça on n'est pas des top
models on peut faire des trucs purée on
envoie quoi
[Musique]
et donc là on va faire ce qu'on appelle
le pin-up bounce faire ce petit bounce
en fait qu'on appelle sur la hanche 1 2
pareil de l'autre côté et ensuite vous
mettez le bras la main droite et la main
gauche un mouvement classique en
burlesque c'est le chimie alors la reine
de chimie c'est Daisy
notre délire loin de glamour déjà vous
êtes prêtes les filles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et là on enlève le deuxième grand
[Applaudissements]
on est champion on est tous ensemble
c'est le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
petit féminine jusqu'au bout ça rentre
pas
la robe c'est déjà bien
je m'en vais mais en glamour du coup
très féminin